hello reject nation it is Greg the
outlet here hey what is your name
actually the engine are yours Morgan and
Morgan than hand from how to's Morgan
and actually go check out their YouTube
channel these two are wonderful it's
it's like hats I tell you it's like hot
Ashley and Morgan are two really good
friends of mine
Ashley and I hop around between me and
best friends every few years it always
depended on how our enemy of enemies
a trio movie coming out that a lot of
people have said you must check it out
it's called toured the pharmacy stars
Andy Samberg
[Music]
everyone was cheating except for me so
partner how do you become an on drugs if
you look on drugs wait if you just a
nicotine on drug
[Music]
think it over some shooting about the
program
[Music]
she's a paper on Danny Glover
you shouldn't can't see me looks like
we're still fine I wonder if you're
worried about you some clothes good I
love it when celebrities have fun at
themselves yeah I was but a tease that
really was a teaser trailer what I
really got fine the trailers are that
looks really funny any sambar if he
loves to do these mockumentary yeah did
pop star never stop never stopping I
want to see that too Aaron and he also
did the I forgot he did an HBO movie
that was a tennis movie that was a
mockumentary same style cuts back to
interviews and stuff yeah I guess this
is one of his formulas that he really
likes to go by and I love when they get
like serious actors to do goofy yes
there's so much you oh my god so many
people just go boom oh that's your lover
no I'm looking for Tina Orlando Bloom
behave silly that yeah because I don't
know I'm not a huge Orlando Bloom fan by
any stretch however seen him be goofy
that's an appealing thing to me because
he's always so serious yeah
that's my kind of comedy right there you
know I didn't even see the regular guy
everybody was yelling yelling crying
plant tells him that he's got a hard-on
yep
Ashley you must pay attention to
trailers there were so much happening I
was too excited okay let me just hit
play right in it you'll see him in a
second they do it close up on his face
just wait wait wait wait wait I don't
know how I missed that
over time yeah I wanna see when is this
coming out July hey you guys have HBR
now or HBO GO
I have HBO this channel oh oh you're
like old school I'm a grown ass he
actually has a channel I don't have any
of it but what you do I do
mm-hmm hey that was fun if not I'll come
over - oh yeah well I watch it on demand
that means you have to shoot vineya hmm
let's get that straight
yeah I got it guys no panic everything
will be okay I'll get to watch this yeah
and Lance Armstrong making fun of
himself I love that because we all know
that he took a lot of cocaine in order
to do the Tour de France I don't think
he took no I believe it was a cocaine
from Colombia there's a documentary
about that whole thing is so good my
hero in the name of it doesn't want to
penguin now I took steroids right I'm
gonna sue suede it up yeah hardcore
mm-hmm I would do steroid treatment fad
no it's not satya testicular cancer let
him take some steroid yeah but ladies
some I can't it wasn't Oh what happened
for a while
hmm but anyway new thing was is like
there's so many people that she's doing
it I was lying Island he was a common TV
demand on drugs if you're not on drugs I
think it's like if you can't beat em
join on like Laguna exactly to kill a
monster you must become the monster
mm-hmm to find the murderer you must
become don't let it consume you to the
point that you are actually yeah I'm a
direct exactly he has only face the
darkness but not let it consume let it
consume you
haha philosophy that's Morgan great
philosophy more than optimal awesome but
we're gonna blossom a rag or gal also
say hey subscribe to the real reject
click notification bells all across the
world hallux use of Morgan and Ashley
look at the long people I said that I
hate to be 100 me Ashley
I called her like I Morgan let's go
check the now you can follow them on
Instagram as well have a good day to all
of the American people and the other
countries that watch this channel let's
call the feet or this hard to see ya
what's holding your local fader